[music playing]
NARRATOR: The sun is hanging
heavy over the great Alaska
Range, where it's taken
Morgan and Margaret
an entire day to perform the
simple task of gathering water.
Yeah, ideally, this would be
nice gravel that you could just
nestle these into,
but might have
to reach in there, actually,
to move a couple of rocks
so it sits down evenly.
NARRATOR: And now with
a spring box in place,
there's one final obstacle in
the way of finishing the job.
MORGAN: Let's pull them all out.
MARGARET: Here, grab that one.
MORGAN: It's a little
trickier than I
expected, getting this thing
put together in the hole.
MARGARET: Oh, don't fall.
MORGAN: That one is big.
It's just so hard to--
there we go.
OK.
There's what I was looking for.
And once the sides freeze, once
the wood freezes to the ice,
it's going to be
there and solid.
OK.
That's cold.
It's pretty much dark.
My hands are freezing
from handling
all those little screws and
the hinges and the cold.
I'm ready to get inside.
Try not to drop this
hinge in the dark here.
Ta-da!
MARGARET: Yay!
MORGAN: Let's dip some
buckets, and cover
this thing up and get inside.
MARGARET: One.
MORGAN: It is a long
reach down into this hole,
but I feel like
because of that, it's
more resistant to
overflow, and it's going
to be even better insulated.
It's more likely to
stay clear of ice.
Snow seals better than anything.
MARGARET: Cool.
You good?
I'll leave the shovel.
MORGAN: Yeah, leave
the shovel here.
MARGARET: Right there.
Shovel marks the spot.
MORGAN: I'm glad we got
this figured out today.
It's going to do a better
job of keeping the hole open,
and it hopefully provides us
with some trouble-free water
for the rest of the winter.
Want some water?
MARGARET: Despite all
the time and effort
that went into it today, you
know it's just part of the day.
Tomorrow we'll go
get water again,
and it'll be a much more
efficient fluid system.
MORGAN: All right,
horses are all watered.
Here.
You need some water.
In your cup.
MARGARET: In the fancy cup.
Hit me again.